[Music]
[Applause]
how can a child save a Thoreau if he's
sentenced to die
tell me Nikolas tell me before you let
our son go
where we begin does not define who we
will become before you I see a bar
built by friendship
family love and loss war and bloodshed
because to protect this world
[Music]
aw Nina's act like it
as you write your oversee across the
mountains and the Seas
the fate of Greece journeys with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you I'm Jonathan Simone
creative director of Assassin's Creed
Odyssey Assassin's Creed Odyssey is more
than just an adventure it truly is a
role-playing journey you will explore on
land and see one of the most iconic and
influential settings in human history
ancient Greece the Golden Age of Athens
saw the rise of democracy
modern medicine revolutionary art and
Western philosophy but it was also a
time of war a devastating conflict
between Sparta and Athens the
Peloponnesian War divided the Greek
world and changed the course of history
in this world of contrasts and
opportunity this land shaped by the gods
rage is a battle between order and chaos
this is where your adventure begins you
a simple mercenary an outcast to take on
an incredible quest to save your loved
ones and become the legendary Greece a
Greek hero Greece desperately needs our
teams in Quebec and from around the
world I've spent the last three years
putting all their energy passion and
dedication into this project we have
continued to transform Assassin's Creed
into an epic RPG experience an RPG in
which you will not just play an odyssey
but your Odyssey shaped by your actions
and choices
and the first choice you'll make had the
start of the game is to choose your
character panic sills or Cassandra
and you played a character for the
entire game you share the bloodline of a
legendary Spartan hero and bear as
mysterious weapon
your turn
[Music]
there need a spear you're old enough now
my father's spirit holds a certain
burden but you are ready think of
Leonidas he can create courage and he
made a great sacrifice you share his
blood and the strength he possessed the
broken spear of Leonidas gives you
access to powerful ranged combat and
stealth abilities that you can unleash
on your enemies
and for the first time we have deeply
changed the way we tell stories in
Assassin's Creed you can now truly
interact with history like never before
perhaps when I was thin up both in
weight and philosophy so tell me were
you able to resolve the situation
without bloodshed the rebel heart guards
I relieved them hmm interesting
you thought the life of a thief and a
murderer was worth more than that of
soldiers doing their duty I wasn't even
thinking about him to be honest and what
of the rebel
[Music]
she should be halfway to Mykonos by now
oh really
you let that lunatic run loose are you
sure that was wise I'm not sure if
watching you was wise our choices are
like ripples on water they seem tiny and
insignificant at the beginning but they
can become devastating tidal waves by
the time they run their course over the
next few days you can experience this
for yourself here at e3 in our playable
demo and for you at home here's a full
gameplay sequence of Assassin's Creed
Odyssey thank you have a grade III
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
such a beautiful island
[Music]
ah
Mykonos Island built from the corpses of
giants slain by the legendary Eve atlas
Britney the note again illegal bearing
mistress
that's you we are a small but fierce
group of rebels who'd pay you handsomely
to help us overthrow our Athenian
oppressors a warrior named Theo Cleese
fights with them none who faced him
survive please miss Diaz
our people are dying signed Kira
[Music]
what did your informant tell you world
has already spread of you sinking those
ships there's a price on your head oh
that didn't take long
there's also world of Spartans landing
on Mykonos so I'm here to find Kira who
wants me to kill their place in Athenian
Ally who's at war with Sparta and don't
forget the bounty business as usual them
gods protect you Cassandra
thanks for nervous but they'll be too
busy protecting via Cleese from me
Hey
personally this can't be good
you're chasing your own you want my hex
commentator
[Music]
[Music]
you really should have left me alone
yeah
[Music]
Barnabas was right the spartans have
made themselves right at home
I'm looking for Kira what do you want
with her
little mercenary who bears the eagle of
Zeus you got my message
it said something about paying me
handsomely mercenaries Athenians have
enslaved their people for too long
help us free Mykonos from their grasp
and you'll have more than meat and you
can carry I'm here to kill Wilk lace not
go to war which is why I sent word of a
rebellion to you and Sparta my men are
ferocious in a ground assault but we're
outnumbered in V Elise fights with the
fury of Ares join us in battle if you're
half the warrior Kira says you are we'll
grind these Athenians into dust
[Music]
all right Spartan I'll fight with you
but the case is mine to battle them
Susan accumulator
your life ends today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]